studios are rethinking whether  theatrical releases are worth it make  the case right now for the big silver  when a movie comes out that you're  interested enough to see  and  it makes you leave your house and buy a  ticket and you can do anything in the  world you want that night but you decide  to go to see a film one film particular  and you go to see it and maybe you're on  your own maybe it's in the afternoon or  maybe it's with your date or your wife  or whoever and you go and see it and you  and you buy a ticket and you sit down  and you have an experience and you have  an experience with a bunch of strangers  and at that moment once the movie gets  going once the lights are down  you become a collective and when you  have a good experience it's not always a  good experience but when you have a good  experience those are the things that  stay in your mind and that you remember  for the rest of your life and they  become indelible  indelible snapshots  okay I'll go to the movies